President Barack Obama has won a second term,...
...overcoming a fierce challenge from Mitt Romney...
...and in the process, becoming the third President in a row to win a second term.
The President surpassed the magic number of 270 electoral votes...
...by winning key states like Ohio, Pennsylvania, Iowa, and New Hampshire.
He won despite coming under withering fire from Romney and other Republicans...
...for his handling of the ailing economy and the soaring debt.
The jobless rate during the president's first term...
...was more than 8 percent until just recently.
Exit polls show that 6 of 10 voters cited rising prices and unemployment...
...as their chief concerns, but more blamed George W. Bush than Obama.
Jerry Bodlander, Associated Press, Washington.